a tragedy is unfolding in
lebanon inflation has driven the
country's currency to historical lows
the crash highlights a grave economic
crisis that has left half the population
living below the poverty line
fire and fury on the streets of beirut
lebanon is descending fast into an
economic crisis that the world bank says
will likely rank among the world's worst
of the last 150 years
all the people are hungry no one has
anything to eat there's no electricity
in our homes
children need milk no one can afford to
buy it that's why we're here
where some streets witness protests
others host long lines of cars
queuing for a share of lebanon's
insufficient supply of gasoline
shortages are pushing up the costs of
many essentials
the price of subsidised bread has been
hiked five times this year alone
citizens are also getting much less for
their money because of record inflation
the lebanese pound has been trading at
an all-time high on the black market
at over 10 times its official rates
against the u.s dollar
the crisis is largely the result of
three decades of financial mismanagement
by successive governments following
lebanon's civil war
but it's been made even worse by a
global pandemic
and the billions of dollars of damage
caused by last year's deadly blast in
beirut port
an outraged lebanese public want their
government to solve the crisis
fast but with the economy on course to
contract by 20
this year the problems are far from over
dw's basil iridi joined us from beirut
uh
basil the reports were getting paint a
very bleak picture of lebanon
what's the situation where you are
we were talking before in the previous
month about the state of
threefold the economic state in three of
threefold now we are talking about
collapse about
hard crisis there will be no soft
landing according to all
experts financial economic experts in
lebanon they're talking about
hard crash and total collapse
this year today according to
the rate financial rate lebanese pound
against the us dollars
according to the black market rates
today it lost
more than 90 percent of its value
against u.s dollars the minimum wage now
in lebanon according today to today's
rate
is 30 us dollar per month which means
one dollar per day
uh we're talking about more than 55
percent of the lebanese population
on and below the poverty line so so we
can we are talking about a very dramatic
situation in lebanon right now
they mean while where there's many roads
are blocked by
by people they're asking the government
to act but unfortunately
there is no one is hearing the sounds of
the people right now
so how can lebanon pull itself out of
this terrible crisis
we have to talk about 30 years of first
of all
corruption second mismanagement and
monopolism
so all these uh all these
substances mixed together with a
corrupted political rulers it lead to
this critical
situation
right and a situation hopefully that can
be resolved eventually uh basil already
there from
beirut thank you so much for your time
thank you